[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
there is a huge update coming to ps plus
this november and i think we should look
at it
in a little more detail to coincide with
the release of the ps5
there will be 18 games free to play
right away
you heard me right 18. i thought we
should quickly break them down so you
know once and for all if you're going to
make the jump to ps5
right away or wait a little while here's
every game so far revealed in the ps
plus collection dropping on november
12th
let's start with the games that have
never appeared on ps plus before and the
biggest game on the list
is god of war the 2018 game of the year
which in many people's eyes is the game
of the generation
playing as kratos as he leads greek
mythology behind to venture into the
lands of odin
and thor and norse mythology a blend of
hack and slash action
reaction based combat and puzzle solving
along the way
but the story is another huge selling
point as we discover secrets about the
god of war and his family
this game has so many 10 out of 10
review scores it will blow your puny
mind
another playstation exclusive is days
gone a zombie apocalypse game in which
cannibalistic freakers are trying to eat
you alive
playing as deacon we survive the
outbreak and move freely around the open
world
thanks to our motorcycle due to many
patches and updates the game is in a far
better place than it was when released
in 2019
and come november it's all yours persona
5 is yet another exclusive title on ps4
this is a role-playing game following
the schedule of a tokyo high school
over the year we discover some special
powers
persona games can be a bit daunting at
first as there is an element of dungeon
crawling digital novels and
even sim-like social scenarios so maybe
if you're still thinking this isn't the
game for you when november arrives you
can try it without putting your money on
the line
you'll be surprised how great this
series is back in 2001
and 2005 two brilliant games released
these were ico
and shadow of the colossus there was a
third game planned but it didn't see the
light of day until
2016 and finished that trilogy
the last guardian has never appeared on
ps plus before but in november
it will so if you've ever wanted to play
as a young boy with a half bird dog
thing following you around
your prayers are answered there are more
playstation exclusives and timed
exclusives but we
had them on ps plus before so i'll
quickly go over them now
let's do the third person action
adventure style games first the last of
us remastered
once again stays attached to ps plus and
the journey of ellie and joel through
zombified america
uncharted 4 a thief's end finishes up
the nathan drake storyline in epic
fashion
infamous second son was on ps plus back
in 2017
and gave us super powers and an open
world with a morality system which lets
us be good
or downright evil i know which one you
chose
the ps4 exclusives keep on coming
bloodborne returns to ps plus in
november which is everything
but another game in the soul series you
know the drill these games are
punishment
as you slowly venture forward you will
die time and time again
these games are for the hardcore purists
which is why
five years later i still haven't
finished it wait there's more exclusive
games until dawn will return to ps plus
as we play through an interactive horror
story perfect for the kids
no it's certainly most not perfect for
the kids it is filled with anxiety and
jump scares
it's great if platforming is your jam
then note that ratchet and clank are
coming back to ps plus too
a perfect chance to be reacquainted
before the new rift apart sequel drops
and the last playstation console
exclusive is the return of detroit
become
human taking control of many synthetic
humans as we choose our own adventure
to fight oppression or to run and hide
this is the game with multiple paths and
endings
with tons of replayability we still have
seven more games to go through
six of them are brand new to ps plus
let's start with horror
resident evil 7 biohazard takes the
third person game and shoves it in first
person
as we take on a new protagonist to find
his lost wife
this game is filled with poop your pants
moments especially in the first three
hours
and it's psvr compatible too which
honestly
is the scariest thing i've ever played
in my life if you prefer to brawl and
check out mortal kombat x
notice that this isn't the latest game
in the series but still
a highly accomplished fighter with
stylized brutal action throughout
a great game to settle disputes at home
what about cooperative hunting
if you have never played a monster
hunter game before try monster hunter
world
you and three other buddies prepare to
track down take down
or capture a legendary animal we then
use their body parts to create
new armor sets and weapons allowing the
squad to take on the next tier of hunt
it's crazy addictive with the right
people and with regular crossover events
like
ryu from street fighter popping up there
is content for months
there's an online first person shooter
included in the collection 2
battlefield 1 the world war 1 outing
from 2016
packed with tons of game modes but i
have to be honest not many people play
this one online these days
it was released in 2016 remember but the
campaign is still
eye-opening remember when fallout games
were great yeah me too
which brings me to fallout 4. another
open world apocalypse filled with toxic
creatures and tentative alliances
fallout 4 is a classic of our time let's
not let fallout 76 ruin this moment
and we can't have a ps plus collection
without a final fantasy game can we
well this time it's final fantasy xv
released in 2016.
this iteration of the franchise includes
the real-time battle system which makes
every encounter more impactful than the
previous turn-based combat
other than that this is the role-playing
game you know the franchise for
and this time there's a flying car too
and finally if anyone is still here the
last game is batman arkham
knight the final part of the arkham
series although we now know this
timeline is continued in the upcoming
suicide squad game
so right now is a good time to look for
references
to that game's continuity using batman's
detective vision
and the utterly brilliant arkham
fighting system too
so there we have it 18 games completely
free coming to ps plus
in november it looks like there's
something for everyone and many
returning games that people loved in the
past
i'd love to know your thoughts and if
you've stayed this long hit me with a
dad joke please
i'll be watching i'm adam from
playstation grenade it's been a pleasure
see you next time